the passenger pigeon was around for six
million years and people remembered how
amazing it was that these animals
darkened the sky for hours at a time
there's these stories about these giant
flocks blocking out the Sun
and their wings sounding louder than
thunder
we developed the techniques to hunt and
met these birds and basically kill them
all
and it was really gone when I was
growing up my mother said when the last
one died in 1914 it broke America's
heart it was one of the prideful things
that America had to show the world it's
gone this book this is essentially the
Bible of passenger pigeon I am currently
the lead researcher for the
de-extinction project to bring the
extinct passenger pigeon back to life
when I say Oh we'll bring back a
passenger pigeon everything goes oh my
god that's like Jurassic Park and no no
it's not not at all our scientists have
done things which nobody's ever done
before yeah yeah but your scientists
were so preoccupied with whether or not
they could they didn't stop to think of
they should I don't think
a pigeon is going to you know pluck
lawyers off of toilets
so how we're actually going to go about
de-extinction every organism has a
unique code in their genes this one we
can I think so these are actual DNA
codes from a chunk of a passenger pigeon
foot now if you can get DNA and we can
actually make it into a living cell
we're going to sequence its whole genome
we're gonna build from scratch the code
that is a passenger pigeon one gene at a
time compare it to its closest relative
we're gonna introduce DNA into the
living cell of a band-tailed pigeon and
when you introduce an extinct animals
egg cell into a new mother then you've
changed the game which has been done
the extinct Iranian ibex was
successfully cloned that was the first D
extinction this particular case the
animal only lived about 10 minutes but
it was a proof of concept and with
further efforts we hope followed by
everything from the passenger pigeon to
the Tasmanian Tiger it's one of the most
famous human-caused extinctions in the
world Benjamin the last Tasmanian tiger
died in 1936 it was our direct activity
that caused that extinction for me
biotech is the future of conservation
because our meddling is not unnatural it
is what species do one of the things
that have gotten used to is the
horrifying realization that extinction
is forever
but what if the new truth is the D
extinction is forever